curry the rebound sorry
long-distance well beyond the arc his
first three-pointer of the finals now
makes the door pop Thompson gets inside
count it and a foul hurry so good at
taking a big man off the dribble much
everything as you talked about coach and
Steph Curry gets the matchup he wants
we've seen that time and time again the
ability to blow by doesn't matter if as
a big man off point God he's gonna get
to his spot he changes to the Cavs and
of course is a season pass deflected by
green curry and Durant 30 throws it up
Durant throws it down wanted to make
sure his team came with that focus in
that force to begin curry way hot side
that's another three to long
three-pointers for curry and were tied
again five to shoot the curries Tristan
Thompson trying to stay with him curry
takes him to the basket blocked by
Thompson rejected out of Bounce 1.5 to
shoot now for Golden State
Jake young high arcing shot as good as
the shot clock expires
Smith whips that out Kevin Love gets a
good look for three short JR Smith the
rebound back the love inside layups good
and one great two passes by JR Smith and
another player acquired midseason from
the Lakers playing in his first playoffs
than obviously his first Finals curry
backs at home little push shot from 12
feet off the glass and these are shots
that he works on before the game to the
log back door nice spin off the glass
see feet draymond Green back doored
Kevin Love with nine points here in the
first four but there should have been
support on that cut I speed inside
Jordan Bell comes up short
look great to see him back on the floor
James drives has Livingston and probit
sit down LeBron James so aggressive
offensively to start he's got 14 I mean
if you're David West you got to get
turned you should be in help you're not
seeing the ball
[Applause]
regarding Larry Nance Jr like he's Kevin
Love account he's on the Lakers losing
games and here he is in attempt gets it
inside and lays it up an end got away
from the warrior defense that's a great
offensive sequence and he'll get to
steal at the other end
[Applause]
[Music]
he'll mask green touch pass to Nance a
beautiful play for green fancy passes to
the calf stay with it curry the runner
banks at home again another difficult
shot both ways the referees on loud on
the place curry whips a pass inside the
green beautiful dish and the foul Steph
Curry with his fifth assist of a chance
for a three-point play bumped again lost
the ball three on one break carry the
Duran for the slam reporte won't go
Durant the rebound still plenty of time
no fouls to get for Cleveland ahead to
curry curry sets fires puts it up way
downtown
and the first half comes to an end in
dramatic fashion Steph Curry gets a
wide-open look we've seen this time and
time again from about 30 feet out Steph
Curry finishes the first half with 18
points James at 24 or halftime of Game
one we played in nine of the games so
far in these playoffs nine of the 17 two
ran off one foot grant now with 13
points huge ovation from the Warriors
crowd great job of taking the challenge
and defending LeBron and George Hill
will the bucket to answer draymond Green
to JaVale McGee instant impact from the
big man but loved the rebound screams
tires a three that's good LeBron James
from way downtown and they've tied the
game and this 7o run all from number 23
for all even at 68 apiece Devin love the
rebound I'm shocked you downplay
Savannah's he said she was all City
James again from downtown LeBron brings
it up the floor and pulls up from deep
but you can do with that so that's a
big-time shot how about this cavaliers
bouncing back a ten-point turnaround
here on the third curry answers back
purring with his fourth three-pointer
Shaun Livingston drives pass inside all
beautiful look veloute with a finished
timeout have played missed five shots in
a row
Cleveland's transition defense Epson
letting them down
Bell to Durant got to be able to try to
do a little bit of both and then the big
thing Mike is what do you do late game
against these great players Jeff Green
running the floor and throws it down
green his first field goal and was just
terrific
[Applause]
James drives and finishes the slam
brings the cats back within four give
him plenty of room James drives on him
layup off the glass banks at home 40
points for James this eighth 40-point
game of the playoffs this year
hurry for free
[Applause]
Steph Curry one-on-one against Kevin
Love knocks down the jumper exciting
times in the Bay Area floria's up six
[Music]
[Applause]
games drives past Durant gets inside
layup is good and it's back to poor we
get under three minutes remaining
James drives past curry gets inside and
throws it down a two-point game 44 for
James Murray again on the switch picks
up James eight to shoot
James drives shot blocks count it and
one
LeBron James puts the Cavs up one will
the free throw coming up I'm in time
again making big-time plays gets into
the thick of the warrior defense grown
man move takes the contact and scores
the hoop this 46 points is his Finals
career-high
but if Golden State get to stop and
decides not to take a timeout James
drives double clutches and puts it in 49
for James and LeBron with the hang time
and defendant and they go quick Mike so
they give themselves an opportunity to
get the ball back but they don't have
defenders in curry tries
and hurry off the glass got a chance for
a three-point play
they're offensive players in absolutely
late help here love no question gets big
free throws here
[Applause]
still misses rebound goes on the cab JR
Smith brings it back out throws to the
hill he'll stop block and we'll go to
overtime
Phil misses rebound goes on the cab JR
Smith brings it back out throws on the
hill he'll stop block and we'll go to
overtime you get the feeling juniors no
thought they had the lead they don't
know the score I think exactly that's a
bad mistake by Jo Smith and LeBron James
was trying to get a timeout and a bronze
James is what George Hill drives to the
basket
Isis sweep it in can't get it to fall
draymond Green the rebound curry to
draymond Green back to Thompson corner
three
what's it in curry drives to the basket
throws it behind his back to Livingston
Livingston jump hook bounces in timeout
Cavaliers
draymond Green Watson pass inside the
Livingston cuts him frozen down nine
point gain slip off the flare screen
anticipating he's switch game shot mrs.
Jeffries tip is good at nine point lead
by the way the largest of the game for
Golden State out to Livingston Green
fires away that's a three draymond Green
from downtown each point cushion as we
approach a minute remaining pass inside
the green throws it out Thompson catches
fires connects
klay Thompson
six on the 24 curry on the drive scoop
layup game may have gotten a piece of it
as jr. Smith comes the other way Hill up
top
Smith launches a three-pointer knocks it
down curry on the drive scoop layup
James may have gotten a piece of it as
jr. Smith come to the other way Hill up
tops Smith launches a three-pointer
knocks it down
[Applause]